Matt Gates um Congressman you know you
faced uh unfair persecution yourself
um by our our you know powers that be in
our justice system but Bragg just you
know indicted a former president
for the first time in our history and
yet they don't have to tell the American
public right now why for a few days just
to keep the the drama going I guess your
reaction did just that aspect of it
before we get into more
it seems to leave a nation on the edge
as we witness the Soros Suffocation of
the criminal justice system in this
country remember soroscave Alvin Bragg a
million dollars and we're used to seeing
these things with uh political leaders
arrested grandmothers hijacked in our
city centers government printing money
till it goes out of style in third world
countries and now that's being visited
on the United States of America I spoke
with President Trump moments ago and he
is Resolute and focused and he's
concerned about what this does to
America's brand around the world we will
wake up in a very different America
tomorrow because we can no longer have
moral Authority against the dictators
and despots who would always find it
easier to jail their political Rivals
than to compete against them in free and
fair elections and I remember my
Democrat colleagues in Congress just
crowing to high heaven about the
unfairness of Comey making derogatory
comments about Hillary Clinton before
the 2016 election this must ring a
thousand times louder to all of them it
is clear election interference and I
believe there are federal equities at
play that the United States Congress
ought to evaluate Now Matt Congressman
sorry um do you agree with what I said
in the angle that if Biden and the White
House didn't want this to go forward it
wouldn't have gone forward right I mean
they would have been a back Channel
communication or or a public speech
about how we have to set aside our
differences and may the best man or
woman win in 2024 we have to unite the
country you know don't you know
prosecute your political opponents we
got to put that put that away that
concept away he could have made it would
have actually been smart politically for
him but he didn't do that
so they are approving this they they
they're going to say they're not but
they're they're they're approving of
this entire thing oh not only did Joe
Biden not put out a message to bring the
temperature down he functionally gas lit
this indictment by saying that extreme
Maga Republicans were dangerous remember
it's Biden's government that we are
currently investigating for
supercharging the notion of domestic
violent extremism we found cases of the
FBI cooking the books to try to get
every American to think that the person
next to them with a pro-trump bumper
sticker is somehow dangerous or evil and
when Biden did that it created a
permission structure not only for Alvin
Bragg but for the corrupt left-leaning
prosecutors in Fulton County and even
for the special counsel to try to lash
together anything remember this is a
novel legal Theory you're talking about
a misdemeanor that has to get
bootstrapped onto election law in a way
I've never seen before and Alvin Bragg
made this promise in his campaign he
told New York voters that he had sued
Trump a hundred times and that if he got
in that position he would continue this
terrible Witch Hunt yeah he's a total
hack I mean we all know that I mean
anyone who's a serious person knows this
is political it doesn't pass the
straight face test but Michael Cohen's
attorney yes he has an attorney thinks
the prosecutors Congressmen have a lot
to work with
there are lots of facts lots of
documents lots of evidence of multiple
crimes there will be a lot of people
surprised at the level of evidence that
the detail of evidence based on my
experience in watching this group of
prosecutors develop this case
Congressman again their in essence
allowed to just pedal propaganda before
the public
even knows what Trump is facing here
again it's almost like they're trying to
it's almost like they're trying to
incite some type of of bad reaction on
the part of the American people by kind
of dragging this out I don't like this
and and everybody watching tonight we
you know support peaceful protests and
people are going to protest this go at
it but you know we're not violent people
we go to court to get our results if we
have to yeah we don't want Donald
Trump's going to do certainly we don't
want to resolve differences through
violence but give me a break the Chinese
Communist Party can pay every grifter in
the Biden family but Donald Trump
campaign Stormy Daniels to resolve a
legal dispute without the claim that
there's lots of evidence there's a legal
element that is not met by any evidence
they would have to prove that Donald
Trump would have no reason other than
the election to try to resolve this
issue with Stormy Daniels privately and
outside of the public sphere and of
course there are plenty of reasons he
would do so so is an obvious affirmative
defense what I think will happen next a
motion to dismiss and if this were ever
to be tried you certainly could not do
it in Manhattan you would likely see a
change of venue Upstate New York would
maybe be the only place Donald Trump
could get a fair trial but what I expect
is that this will be resolved well
before that by any court that looks at
the way that the law is being tortured
in the absence of any charge that would
be maintainable against any human being
on the planet Earth other than Donald
Trump and against trump it is clearly
political frivolous and that's why
you're able to cite that Quinnipiac
evidence showing that by a margin of
about two to one the American people see
this is not based in the law or the
facts but raw ugly politics you have
more faith than the judges in New York
than I do Congressman I don't I don't
have any faith in these judges in New
York but maybe I've just seen too much
in my day but we appreciate it
Congressman thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else